all right filter vials now filter vials  they eliminate the need for vials caps  syringe filters and syringes easily  helping you separate your solution  pre-slit caps make it easy to extract  your solution and snap top caps help  make it easy to close the cap now crimp  caps help minimize evaporation the most  out of all the styles of caps they just  require the most amount of work to put  on since you have to use a crimp on them  via an electronic or manual crimping  tool and ptfe are for applications that  require more chemical resistance and  nylon filters are great for aqueous  samples or aqueous and organic sample  mixes